zov is a theme that runs through the
whole poem as you can see it is love
that drives the lover towards his
beloved it is love that leads him to
forsake and forget his own self to
become annihilated in the south of
reality
and that is that love which permeates
the heart of the enlightened Mystic as
he experiences that love as the nature
of all things every Adam of me
witnessing her loveliness with every
glance of every shining eye
all my subtle words adoring her with
every tongue profused with praise
smelling her sweet scent with every
fiber of every nose breathing in the
rising air
every bit of me hearing her word with
the ear of all hoping to hear
every part of me kissing her veil with
every mouth and each touch and kiss
had she unrolled my body she would have
seen every essence with every heart
holding every love